- (Mark) All right, Stacy.
- Yes.
- (Mark) Stacy, where
are you from originally?
Where'd you grow up?
- I grew up in North Carolina
in a small town called Asheboro.
But I really was, I mean
I was raised in the woods.
That's all I did was.
- (Mark) So this is
Western North Carolina?
- No, like the middle.
- (Mark) Center?
- Yeah,
you know where the zoo is?
- (Mark) I don't.
- Okay, well that's where it's at.
- (Mark) Cool.
And tell me about your childhood,
you grew up with both of your parents?
- No, my, well, until I was
about two I had both my parents
but they fought so much
that they ended up
drawing guns on each other
and my mom left my dad,
so I was raised by my mom.
Single parent household.
I'm mixed, I'm half black, half white,
raised in the South.
And I tell people, it's like,
it's one thing being white and
it's one thing being black,
it's another thing being mixed.
It's like you're just caught in the middle
and you have, you just don't
know which way you're gonna go
at any given point.
- (Mark) Which one do you relate to more?
- Probably my white side
just because I was raised
by my mom who is white.
- (Mark) Yeah.
And how was your childhood?
- I mean, I thought it was okay,
but I normalized what was going on.
My mom drank, I mean
she was a binge drinker
and she would sometimes pass out
and I'd have to take care of
my little sister and brother
and nurse her back to health
when she had hangovers.
And we would go to juke joints.
And I mean, it was just,
I mean to me it was normal
but it wasn't normal.
- (Mark) No, but do you say
- Yes, I got molested when I was,
I don't know, eight or nine.
- (Mark) By who?
- My neighbor, it was an old man.
- (Mark) While mom was drunk?
- I don't remember if when she was drunk
or she just, we just went over there
and he told me he'd give me
money if I let him touch me
so I did.
- (Mark) Did that go on a long time?
- A few months until I
finally told somebody.
- (Mark) And what happened to him?
- Nothing.
- (Mark) Nothing?
Common story.
And then what age were
you when you left home?
- I started running away when I was 14
and I left when I was 16.
I moved out on my own when I was 16,
but I went from being in the
country to go into the city
and it was the fast life
and I got mesmerized by it
and chased it, that was it.
- (Mark) Where'd you go?
- Just in the city part of Asheboro.
I lived on the outskirts,
that's where I grew up.
So the first time I got there,
when we first moved there
all the lights were on all night long,
you know like street lights.
We didn't have that in the country.
If you wasn't at home by like
5:30 or six in the evening
you were stuck out in the dark.
So that was different and great.
- (Mark) And what were you doing for,
how were you surviving?
- I worked and I prostituted myself.
- (Mark) Really?
And were drugs in the picture then?
- Mm hmm.
- (Mark) Which drugs were you using?
- By that time cocaine, crack, marijuana
and alcohol.
- (Mark) So do you have
kids of your own now?
- I have one.
- (Mark) Did you raise?
- She's with my mom.
I did for like the first
three years of her life
and then I just keep going in
and out of doing really good
and then doing really bad.
And I don't know it's like,
I have to tear myself down
just to build myself up.
Like I've had homes and
cars and really good jobs.
I've went to school, I'm a nurse,
but I just can't seem to
stay away from the gutter.
- (Mark) What is it do you think
that keeps taking you down?
- Myself, my thoughts about myself.
- (Mark) Do you think, is
it like your self-worth,
you just think you belong down here?
- It seems to be easier
for me to build myself up
when I'm down here.
If I'm at the top with people
I don't feel like I fit in.
I feel like an imposter.
Yeah.
But I know that.
I mean, I wanna believe that
I'm good enough to be there
because I can perform, but it's
my mind that tells me that.
- (Mark) Your thoughts just tell you that.
- Yeah, that I'm not good enough,
that they really don't like me,
that I don't even know why I'm doing this
'cause it's all gonna end
up being a disaster anyway
and then I end up making it a disaster.
- (Mark) What do you
think that stems from?
Is it your parenting?
Is it your brain chemistry?
Is it your being molested?
- I think it stems from a lot of things.
I mean you were touching on it.
My parenting, I have
mental health disorders.
Just not really coping healthy
and then being introduced to drugs.
I mean, once that comes, it's like,
it's the hardest thing I've
ever had to do is stop.
- (Mark) Do you think being
molested at eight years old
may have kind of planted
that seed of low self worth?
- I mean I think that that
has something to do with it
and, you know, something to do
with me prostituting myself too.
'Cause like I said, he offered me money
to touch my boobs.
- (Mark) So where are you staying now?
- I was staying in the
van with my boyfriend,
but we got in a fight last night
and I don't know where I'm staying now.
I'll probably end up going back home.
- (Mark) And where's back home?
- North Carolina.
- (Mark) Oh, so you'll go
back to North Carolina?
- Yeah, I don't wanna stay
here and be trapped here.
- (Mark) Your daughter's back there.
- She's what?
- (Mark) Your daughter's back there right?
- Yeah.
So are my parents, my
whole family's there.
- (Mark) How old is your daughter?
- She's seven.
- (Mark) I'm sure she'd
be happy to see you.
- Yeah.
- (Mark) Have you been clean before?
- Yup.
Few times.
- (Mark) And so your drug today is what?
- Today?
- (Mark) Yeah.
- I've been smoking crack.
- (Mark) Crack?
Have you tried some of the other drugs?
- Have I tried other drugs?
- (Mark) Yeah.
- Not really my thing.
It's the crack that keeps pulling me down.
- (Mark) And what have
you been doing for money?
What have you been doing
for money out here?
- I have a job.
I actually am an admissions coordinator,
I get people into treatment.
- (Mark) Interesting, huh?
- Yeah.
- (Mark) Do you still,
do you stay in contact
with your daughter and your mom?
- Mm hmm.
- (Mark) Yeah so.
- Yeah I call, I FaceTime
or video chat them.
- (Mark) Yeah, sometimes a tough break,
like what happened last night for you
actually could be a good
thing in the long run.
- I hope something good starts happening.
- (Mark) Yeah, I think,
I think looking,
- I'm just tired.
- (Mark) Looking at your
self sabotaging behaviors is,
it's the key to a lot of this stuff.
'Cause I keep hearing the same
story over and over again,
that people believe they deserve this.
They think they belong down here.
I mean, clearly nobody belongs down here.
All right, well thank you
so much for talking to me.
- You're welcome.
I'm sorry, I'm.
- (Mark) Yeah, I know it's
been a rough night for you.
- Yeah it has.
- (Mark) Well, good luck with everything
and I hope you get to see your daughter.
- Thank you.
- (Mark) All right, thank you.